my mother was uh really her level of
sarcasm was such that she couldn't you
know there was always you know you never
got it straight but before about two
weeks before she passed we actually had
uh that moment did you yeah we I
realized my mother and I had never
really looked in each other's eyes
that's
interesting and what made you think that
you like caught our gaze and you thought
that we sat we because when I said
goodbye you know basically we there was
that moment and I'm holding hand and
she's lying in bed and we just were
staring at each other for I'd say 30
seconds to a minute just quiet just
quiet and that was a life changer cuz I
feel like you know thank
you yeah we're moving on yeah so thanks
for making me nearly cry okay this is
not okay I don't come to LA to cry
the Honeydew with Ryan
sichler